Hey,
have you seen the new Leonardo Dicaprio
movie?
Man,
that guy is such a good actor.
He's so lucky.
He has that talent is rich.
It doesn't even have to do any hard
work.
Good afternoon everyone.
Today I'm going to talk about whether
some people are naturally just good with
languages and other people are not good
with languages.
Usually when people hear about how I
speak several different languages and I
love studying languages,
they often say to me,
wow,
you're so lucky you can speak those
languages.
Now.
That's kind of makes me laugh usually,
but it's also kind of annoying because
I'm not lucky.
I worked really hard to learn all of
those languages,
but people don't really see that.
Sometimes they just see the final
result,
which is that I can speak these
languages.
They don't see all of the effort and the
process that went into it.
They just see that final,
uh,
the final result and they think,
oh,
I couldn't do that.
So they think that it's somehow,
it just a natural talent that I have.
But actually I'm not talented with
languages.
I just love studying languages and
that's why I can easily put in the time
and I can kind of slug through all of
the grind to get good at a language.
People who say I'm not good with
languages,
they usually have no idea what goes into
the process.
They don't realize that it takes
hundreds and hundreds of hours to get
pretty good with the language and it
takes thousands of hours to get really
good at a language.
Probably they hear about people getting
good at a language in three months or in
six months and they think,
wow,
that's really a short period of time.
It sounds easy and they buy in to the
marketing and all that kind of thing.
Um,
but they don't realize that within that
short amount of time,
people who get good at a language or
probably just completely focused and
dedicated and obsessed with that
language.
Like if you get good at a language in
six months and you're fluent,
that means you busted your ass that
whole six months and that language
became your life.
Uh,
learning a language is like climbing a
mountain,
right?
Um,
it's a struggle and it's a challenge
every step of the way.
But that's why it's fun.
So some people endure that grind and
endured the challenge because they love
it or because they're really motivated
by that goal of reaching the top.
And it's the same as people who climb
real mountains.
Why did they climb it?
Not because it's easy,
but the climate because they love the
challenge or they really enjoy getting
to the top of the mountain,
right?
So it's not that it's easy,
it's that some people just love the
challenge and that's why they can stick
it out and they can grind through it.
And that's why they can put in the time
and the effort to get really good at it.
So some people are not good at languages
because they have bad habits,
bad study habits,
or just bad habits of hard work in
general,
or they have bad strategies for
learning.
Both of those are things you can change.
So people can get good with languages
even if they're not right.
Now,
let me tell you just a couple of
examples.
Like,
uh,
one guy who I used to work with at my
previous job,
he told me,
uh,
well,
I,
I can speak Japanese quite well and he
can't speak Japanese very well.
And he was saying to me,
Oh,
I wish I could speak at like you.
And I said,
well,
why don't you do it then?
And he said,
well,
I've tried,
but I'm not good with languages,
which made my eyebrows raise.
Like,
really?
How much do you study?
And he said,
well,
I study,
you know,
when I have time.
And that was the first red flag.
It was just when I have time,
that's an excuse to not commit to a
study schedule.
So I said,
well,
how often?
He said,
well,
once or twice a week sometimes.
Uh,
and I said,
okay,
when you study on those days,
how much do you study?
And he says,
well,
I try to do a page or two and my
textbook,
I said,
what do you mean try?
Do you do a page or two or we're not?
And he said,
well,
sometimes.
And so all these things,
like you sometimes do a page or two,
uh,
you tried to do a page or two,
what does that mean?
You either do it or you don't.
There is no try.
So if you're going to do three pages
today,
do three pages,
don't do a page and then go on,
I'm tired,
I'm going to go watch TV.
No,
screw that you do your three pages.
That's the kind of commitment.
That's the kind of habit that you need
to get good at a language.
It's that ability to just set a goal and
fight through it because you enjoy it
and because you want to reach that,
that goal at the end,
and that's part of the process is just
committing to it.
So some people can force themselves to
do that and those are the people who are
supposedly good with languages for the
most part.
Another example is someone who has just
a kind of habit or a learning style or a
personality trait that kind of blocks
them from getting good at the language.
I know another guy who tried to learn
Japanese,
kind of tried to learn Japanese,
but he never made any progress with it.
Um,
and I would always ask them,
how's it going?
He said,
oh,
it's not so easy.
I'm not good with languages like you.
And I would dig in a little bit.
And what it is is this guy just loves to
talk your ear off.
He's one of these people who just talks,
talks,
talks all the time really fast.
And he can't slow himself down.
And he absolutely hates listening to
other people.
Like stopping his own voice to listen to
other people is,
it causes him like psychological terror
almost.
He just hates it.
Um,
so he's not someone who can slow himself
down enough to really go slowly when
learning a language.
He has to just say all his ideas right
away or he feels freaked out.
So when you're learning a language,
of course you need to sometimes go
slowly.
You need to,
you know,
uh,
process the concepts,
process the patterns and piece together
your sentences.
You need to just,
um,
you need to slow down to make your
speech more accurate.
And if you are not used to doing that,
if you have a personality trait that
inhibits you from slowing down,
and that means you need to change that
strategy,
you need to work on that part of your,
of your personality in order to help you
learn better,
right?
So it's not that that guy is not good
with languages is that he,
he has this,
uh,
this pattern of behavior that stops him
from,
from pushing forward in his learning,
right?
So if he can work on that,
then he can get better with learning
languages.
So if you have trouble learning
languages,
it could be one of those two things.
It could be that you don't have the
study habits so you don't have the
habits of setting goals and just
fighting through all of the bullshit
that you have to go through to reach
your goal.
Or it could be that you have some kind
of,
some kind of,
um,
uh,
trait or some kind of pattern that's
inhibiting your learning and you can
figure out what that is.
And try to work around that or try to
change it so you can learn more
efficiently and not have to keep
stopping.
So that's my basic message.
If you think you're not good with
languages,
I basically disagree with you and I
think you could be good with languages
if you just change something around and
change your patterns,
change your habits.
Nobody is inherently good with
languages.
Nobody's inherently bad with them.
Have a good day.